let's bring in daryl morey the Rockets
GM nice little offseason and now he can
talk without getting in trouble because
we tried to get him on he said I have to
wait till this deal is official with
Russell Westbrook and Darryl joins us on
the program how's your offseason been
Darryl good hey get two MVPs now so
we're happy all right how much do you
confer with your head coach Mike
D'Antoni on making this work with James
Harden and Russell Westbrook a lot I
mean we're we're pretty tight-knit group
at the Rockets group decision-making and
obviously you know there's there's a
final decisions made but everyone's
input is really important when how long
you've been working on getting Westbrook
moved pretty quickly it was you know
just the Paul George situation obviously
opened the window and did not anticipate
him being available until that happened
and then moved about over the next six
days or so after that we'll wait once
you knew Paul George was on the move
then do you call up Sam Presti and the
Thunder and say Russell Westbrook
available not quite first reached out
just to say hey you know what's the
direction of the team now obviously when
a move like that happens it makes you
say hey maybe that teams go in a
different direction alright so then how
do you come up with do you start the
offer or do they come back and say hey
by the way we're thinking about moving
Russ you interested first ask for the
direction of the team and then after
that we we discussed okay maybe they're
maybe they're looking at the possibility
of moving some of their other key
players spoke with ownership with Coach
D'Antoni with James Harden and you know
acquiring Westbrook at that point was
something that we were interested in and
and then it's a matter of just working
out working out the details about how to
do it what was hardens reaction when you
first broached the topic very
enthusiastic because you know he knows
he plays well together with him because
they
both on OKC and USA basketball and
growing up so he was enthusiastic do you
are you waiting for the apology with me
or do you want to wait till the very end
of the interview you can never say never
that's why when you said that he he was
not tradable untouchable Harden and Paul
and I went the only reason why Paul is
untouchable is because of that contract
I think if he had a better contract and
you could have moved him you would have
moved him and I said that when you were
done with the interview and I still feel
that way that contract was tough to move
and you somehow moved it so I applaud
you on that but I do accept your apology
when you said on this show that you know
I would say I should always say 99.9 and
every thought russell westbrook would
become available in terms of like the
one thing I would disagree people talk
about you know players with unknowable
contracts when here when you're a top 25
player in the league which I think Chris
Paul is you do you if you can't really
overpay them people people sort of miss
that there's there's maybe more
efficient ways to spend money but the
reality is that's only if you can have a
baseball roster roster of you know 15
guys who might play and impact the game
and invest well it's really your only
only our first few guys and only seven
or eight who play at all so you need
your top for you to be top top in the
league so and Chris Paul is amazing for
us and still a very very good player how
much friction was there between Harden
and Paul with just playing style or you
know I guess you can incorporate a lot
of things into that topic but how much
friction was there yeah I think we
talked about that last time I mean for
me it was it was less friction than you
might expect for most superstars we've
had a lot of superstar pairings at the
Rockets and Chris and then James got
together really well
really okay yeah it felt like it was
getting more hero ball
Chris Paul cared for and it felt like
there were a couple of moments where you
know he's he's saying something or
addressing hardened and hardness
dismissing that and I don't know if
we're making we made too much of it but
it just felt like Chris Paul where's his
feelings on his sleeve and he was the
one that was not hiding it how do you uh
yeah both you I I didn't I didn't see I
didn't see a lot of tension there for
sure they had the interaction in game
six that people wrote about but I that
was like 40 times a year for me so I
thought you mate spent too much was made
of it yeah he's daryl morey the Rockets
GM joining us Dan Patrick show this
whole tampering and if you were
Commissioner or you were going to advise
the Commissioner coming from a general
managers perspective how can we get rid
of tampering well I hope the
Commissioner was on on the right
direction there which is say when the
league has rules they should have rules
that they enforce and they enforce
vigorous rigorously so some of the
tampering rules were we're basically
impossible to enforce and I made it made
a bad look for the league so I think you
know that sounds like they're in the
direction of loosening up some of the
conversation rules while keeping some of
the rules that are real you know more
more and more direct tampering with
inducements and things like that so it
seems like Commissioner Silver's on the
right the right path but they haven't
passed anything yet yeah you certainly
take the analytical approach and I'm
wondering now what you think of load
management with to higher energy guys on
your team now and how important it is to
have Harden and Westbrook rested for the
postseason so is load management part of
the strategy for you yeah we try not to
label it or make it a make it a big deal
we have a great great training staff and
obviously our goal is just to win the
title this year we're not you know
looking for any regular season goals
everyone on our teams one such every
award you can accept accepted
championships so
yeah it'll be a very very put-together
plan by our staff throughout the season
to have our guys peak in April is there
anybody you would take over Harden in
your basketball career as far as just
being able to score the basketball you
can have anybody not even close actually
like Jordan it would not take Jordan
over James Harden oh oh you mean like
yeah all of this I thought you meant
someone it was on the Rockets oh no no
no no no no so anybody you can have
anybody I I'm pretty first with our guy
in terms of just scoring yeah just she
just say efficient scoring you know
James Harden's number one so what do you
think Jordan would average now he's a
really really good player so he would
average 45 Darryl well we have to get we
have to get stats ink to create classic
basketball so wait wait you really think
Harden is a greater score now he's a
better shooter they're different but
harden takes advantage of everything he
can possibly take advantage of but do
you think he's a better score just score
then Michael Jordan I mean if you look
historically and you just say how you
know given the number of times he has
the ball and give it and given how how
efficient I think the only one it comes
close is actually Wilt Chamberlain when
when you go back to your history so yeah
how many how many points you're gonna
score after I give you the ball you or
your team it's it's really James and
wilt he's working on a new move and he
says it's not traveling I think the last
move he worked on he said was not
traveling either have you seen this new
move by James Harden that's not
traveling I have not I've never seen
James Harden travel so
that's funny double step back step back
my I watch him travel every game yeah oh
all the time there is he gonna put out a
video that says this is not travelling
so everybody in the NBA including the
Commissioner will sign off on this I
don't know how it works it's more it's
more like gymnastics you unveil the move
and then they great to catch up with you
Congrats on the deal and we'll hopefully
talk to you as we head closer to the
season Thank You Amanda
yes daryl morey for more Dan Patrick
show tune in the audience channel 239 on
DirecTV stream for free on BR live or
download the Dan Patrick show at
[Music]